hey why do we get caught in here just
shut up attention all players can an
event playoff starting capture the
trophy yo what's going
on
who hurts don't it this division ain't
big enough for both of them
[Music]
huh man I got to show this off to
everyone what the dude I lost the trophy
can you dit the concert come help me
wait am I seeing that
right I'll see you soon 15 that boy
never learn do
[Music]
they wait you don't belong anomaly
detected now capturing hold up where's
the
trophy nothing stopping me this year
believe that no touching for pretender
franchises y'all got to be quicker than
that they always saving great power CS
great POS new players
[Music]
joining